We learned in the imaginary
numbers video, that hopefully
you've watched, that every now
and then in certain equations
you end up with a square
root of a negative number.
You know, you end up with
square root of negative 1 or
square root of negative 9.
And since any real number, when
you square it, is either 0 or
positive, this was
undefined for us.
And then in order to make it
defined in that video, people
came up with this
thing called i.
And you can call that
the imaginary unit,
or just the number i.
And you define i as saying,
well if i squared-- we'll
just make a definition.
This thing called i
when you square it,
it equals negative 1.
And then that simplifies
the idea of taking a
negative square root.
Because then you could say, oh
well the square root of
negative 9 is the same thing as
i times the square root
of 9, which equals 3i.
And how can we say that?
Well, what happens when
you square this thing?
So what's 3i squared?
3i squared is equal to 3
squared times i squared.
This is just exponent
properties.
And that equals 9 times
negative 1, which
equals negative 9.
So 3i squared is
equal to negative 9.
And then if we are kind of
extending the definition of
square roots to negative
numbers, then we can go the
other way around and we could
say 3i is equal to the
square root of negative 9.
And 3i we can call an
imaginary number.
And the word is "imaginary,"
but it's as real as anything.
I mean to some degree, do
negative numbers even exist?
They're just kind of a way of
us-- when we put this sign in
front of things, it just tells
us something about how it
relates to this magnitude.
Anyway, I don't want
to confuse you.
But imaginary numbers tend to
get a bad rap because they're
called imaginary numbers, so
some people think that they
exist less than other things.
But with that said, any number
times this imaginary unit
i is an imaginary number.
When you do the quadratic
equation you realize that
sometimes you end up with
a number that has a
little bit of both.
It has a real part and
an imaginary part.
So let me give you
an example of that.
Let's say I have the
number 5 plus 2i.
That number you might say, oh,
well maybe I can simplify it.
But you really can't.
You can't add a real number
plus an imaginary number.
You can almost kind of imagine
them-- and I don't want to use
the word "imagine" too much--
as in different dimensions.
And so a number that has a real
part, like the 5, and an
imaginary part, like the 2i,
this is called a
complex number.
And you could, if you want,
even graph a complex number.
Let me see.
You could make the
vertical axis.
The vertical axis you could
call it the imaginary axis.
And you could make the
horizontal axis the real axis.
This is a symbol for the
set of real numbers.
And 5 plus 2i, well
it's real part is 5.
So one, two, three, four, five.
That's five.
And it's imaginary part is 2i,
so you go along the imaginary
axis, or the i-axis you
could even say, 2.
And then you would have this
number here called 5 plus 2i.
In future videos I'll actually
do examples where we'll make
more use of complex numbers.
But now that we've defined what
a complex number is, let's see
how we can operate with it.
So what happens when we
add two complex numbers?
Clear image.
So let's say we have
two complex numbers.
One is a plus bi.
So the real part is a, the
imaginary part is bi.
And let's say that I
have another complex
number, c plus di.
And in general the symbol that
people tend to use-- you know,
you always use x for when
you're dealing with equations.
Right?
Like x could be any general
real number when you're
dealing with an equation.
In complex numbers the
convention is to use
z, the letter z.
So, for example, we could
call this the complex
number z sub 1.
And it could have been any.
I mean, this choice
of z is arbitrary.
This is an i right here.
This could be z sub 2.
So what is the complex number
z sub 1 plus z sub 2?
Well that equals this, a plus
bi, plus-- this is z sub
2 right here-- c plus di.
Let me switch colors.
This is getting monotonous.
So when you add two complex
numbers, all you do is you add
the real parts to each other
and you add the complex
parts to each other.
So that equals a
plus b-- oh sorry.
The real parts.
So it's a and c.
Those are the real parts.
So that equals a plus c
plus-- and then you add
the imaginary parts.
b plus d times i.
So you have b i's and d i's.
So when you add them together
you have b plus d i's.
b plus d in the imaginary
direction, you can
almost imagine.
I'm using the word
imagine too much.
So it's pretty easy.
You just add the real and you
add the imaginary parts.
So what happens if you
multiply two complex numbers?
And actually, let's
just go in order.
What happens when
you subtract them?
Well, it's the same thing.
Nothing fancy here. z
sub 1 minus z sub 2.
That's just going to be
equal to-- you subtract
the real parts.
a minus c.
And that's the new real part.
And then you subtract
the imaginary parts.
b minus d times i.
And this will be the
new imaginary part.
So this will be the
new complex number.
What happens when I
multiply the two numbers?
So what is z sub
1 times z sub 2?
Well that equals a plus
bi times c plus di.
And we essentially can
just FOIL it out.
I don't know if you've learned
FOIL in 8th grade algebra,
9th grade algebra.
I don't like it.
I actually just think of
it as the distributive
property twice.
So what we could do is we
can take the c plus di
and distribute it on
each of these terms.
Right?
So this should be equal
to a times c plus di.
Right?
Plus bi times c plus di.
All I did is I took the c plus
di and I multiplied it by this
to get this, and multiplied
it by this to get this.
And then we distribute again.
We get ac plus adi--
this is an i.
I know my i's aren't
looking good.
adi plus-- now
what's bi times c?
Well that's cbi.
And then we have bi times di.
So you get b times
d, which is bd.
And then what's i times i?
It's i squared, or negative 1.
Right?
Times negative 1.
So what does this simplify to?
Well this simplifies to--
I'm going to go back here.
So let's see what
the real parts are.
We have this term, a
times c, that's real.
So ac.
And then this last term,
which was bi times di.
Because we're multiplying i
times i we get a negative 1,
but it becomes real again.
Right?
So we get negative bd minus bd.
So that's our new real part.
So that was this term
and that term are real.
And now what's our
new imaginary part?
Well it's going to be these
two terms added together.
So it's-- I'm running out
of space again-- ad plus
cb, all of that times i.
It's a little easier with real
numbers, and maybe in the next
video I'll use real numbers.
But the important thing to
realize is essentially you just
use the distributive property
and realize that you can only
add real terms to each other.
You can't add a real
to an imaginary.
And you can only add imaginary
terms to each other.
And just remember, when you
have two imaginary numbers
times each other, the i's, when
multiplied times each other,
and you get negative 1.
Now the last operation, when
you divide complex numbers.
This gets a little bit
interesting, and maybe
a little unintuitive.
So what happens if I divide
z sub 1 by z sub 2?
So once again that equals a
plus bi, divided by c plus di.
How do I divide this?
Well, we're going to use a
property that hopefully
you learned in algebra.
That if I multiply-- let me
do this in this corner.
a plus b times a minus b.
What does that equal?
That equals a squared
minus b squared.
And so if I multiply
a complex number.
Let's say, in theory, I
multiply a complex number c
plus di times c minus di.
What do I get?
I get c squared
minus di squared.
And what's di squared
going to be?
It's d squared times negative
1, so it becomes c squared--
oh, I'm out of time.
Actually, let me continue the
division in the next video,
because it can get involved.
See you soon.